sur le thème de la ville de demain ils
étaient trois à concourir pour le prix
du livre de saint quentin en yvelines
gaspard koenig avec l'enfer delphine de
vigan hauteur de les enfants sont rois
et michael christie avec son roman
lorsque le dernier arbre
c'est finalement l'auteur canadien qui
remporte cette récompense son roman
raconte l'histoire d'une famille
américaine assombrie par une
accumulation de secret et de tabous sur
quatre générations des années 1930 aux
années 2030 où les personnages sont
intimement lié à celui des arbres
ja oui je suis très content je suis
honoré écrire un livre qui s'engagent
pour l'écologie la nature avec notre
rôle dans la protection de la nature
c'est pour cela que j'ai utilisé le
sujet des armes le prix du livre était
décerné à moitié par des lecteurs et par
un jury composé de neuf professionnels
une majorité pour michael christie mais
quand même une façon de signaler que les
deux autres heures avait aussi une
portée quand même un regard sur la
société actuelle les fans étaient aussi
au rendez-vous pour saluer le travail de
michael christie
tu viens de demander une dédicace amical
christie parce que j'ai adoré son livre
j'ai déjà lu mais j'ai même voté pour
lui justement pour qu'il obtienne grille
j'adore c'est génial c'est vraiment un
honneur de participer à cette première
édition du salon du livre et je suis sûr
qu'il y en aura d'autres apps et lors de
la cérémonie de remise de prix l'auteur
a remporté la somme de 5000 euros
l'écrivain travaille désormais avec des
producteurs pour adapter son roman à la
télévision il devrait également sortir
un nouveau livre prochainement